what's up chess friends how are you guys
doing i hope you're having a nice day
wherever you are this is spanish
grandmaster pepe cuenca
and i welcome you to this third video
where we talk about the netflix series
the queen's gambit
we already presented two videos as you
know and in this third one we're gonna
analyze
a game that happened in the episode
number six
where elizabeth harmon beth harmon is
facing very vats who is a grandmaster
from the
united states the game is really famous
actually
as you know these games are based on
real games right
and at the end of the analyzes i'm gonna
tell you the names of the real players
but probably many of you know this game
so let's just focus on this fantastic
chess game
between elizabeth harmon and venibats
okay so elizabeth starts with e4 and
benny replies with e5
knight a3 d6 from benny entering in the
so-called philido
defense my favorite one i've been
playing this line for 20 years
so as you guys probably know knight c6
or not f6 are the main move
so knight f6 going for the 12th defense
but d6 by benny now d4
occupying the center and here benny goes
for bishop g4 this is considered to be
inaccurate nowadays i'll try to explain
you why
in few seconds the main move nowadays is
it takes e4
knight takes e4 not f6 knight c3 and
bishop e7
and for example you have seen magnus
carlsen or daniel dubois
playing this line in the last months in
the magnus tour tournaments
so definitely very very playable but
after bishop g4 the problem is that
after d
takes e5 black is now forced to give out
the bishop pair on f3
because if black takes on e5 now queen
takes d8 first
king takes d8 and knight e5 this is just
a healthy pawn
up for white and we are putting pressure
on f7 on the bishop on g4 and this game
has
lost the right to castle so this is why
this is considered to be
much better for white after dxe5
black is therefore forced to take on f3
and after queen takes a three d takes f5
e5 sorry
we have the bishop bear um black has
achieved nothing
in return so this is why this is an
inaccurate
variation nowadays so now beth continues
with bishop c4 the best iona for this
bishop just trying to give up to keep
checkmate
in the next move on f7 and now black
paris that threat with the move knight
f6
probably a little bit better is queen f6
in this position
now white continues with queen b3
putting pressure on b7
and now knight d7 is actually very
interesting because after quintex b7
rook b8 there are actually some tricks
in this position
you shouldn't take on a7 because of
bishop c5
boom attacking the queen and attacking
f2 with these two pieces and basically
white is losing i mean same problem
arises
after queen c7 now bishop d6 is very
strong there are no squares for the
queen
you cannot take on a7 because of bishop
c5 you cannot go
queen a5 because of bishop b4 just
winning the queen
and after queen c6 there is a nice
intermediate
sorry discover check with bishop b4 just
winning the queen in the next move
so you should be very careful after rook
b8 and probably white should go
queen a6 after queen a6 bishop a6
uh still has a great advantage in this
position because
white is a healthy pawn up again
but after bishop c4 veni goes for knight
f6 and now
queen b3 attacking b7 and attacking f7
now black cannot protect uh both
both squares at the same time with a
piece right
so it's difficult to do two things at a
time right so for example i don't know
if you guys have tried
uh i i love singing you know i love
singing when i'm taking a shower you
know i start singing some [ __ ] and then
uh okay singing is easy even though i
sing terribly but okay you can you can
sing yeah
but uh you try to sing and then play the
guitar i don't know how
the musicians you you know for me it's
just impossible you know just trying to
create some
rhythm with my hands you know and then
trying to say it's just impossible for
me you know
i look so stupid so here black has the
same trouble black has to protect
both both squares f7 and b7 is actually
not possible to do
to do it so this is why white is on top
in this position
and black tried queen e7 which is a good
move
because after queen b7 black is not
losing the rook
as it looks because of queen b4 check
and black managed to trade queens
at least of course again this is a very
good position for white but at least
black is not losing immediately so
after queen e7 elizabeth harmon says you
know what i don't want to
go for an ending just for the pawn up so
i just want to crush you
and that's why she just developed the
knight to c3
now white is ready to continue with
bishop g5 and land
long castle so black protects b7 by
playing c6
which is a good move because also
controls the d5 square
and now bishop g5 and black is is in
some sort of
suitspan right because it's just
impossible to develop the queen side of
after knight b to d7
b7 falls after knight a6 bishop takes a6
ruins black pawn structure and is uh
it's not easy to develop the queen the
king side sorry because there is a queen
on e7 just
stopping this bishop development let's
say after h6
we can't just take on f6 and then this
forces black to take with the pawn
otherwise it black takes with the queen
queen takes b7 now wins the game on the
spot
so she takes f6 and then long castle and
again this is just
a disaster for black
so this is why veni went for b5 you know
asking this bishop where he wants to go
it's clear
that if now white retreats the bishop to
d3 now black can develop the knight to
d7
because there is no pressure on b7 and
this knight is actually joining the body
on c5 where actually it annoys a lot
this queen on b3 this queen on b3 hasn't
got many squares in this position
so this is why this is a critical moment
and elizabeth harmon
replied with the best move in the
position which is
knight x b5 sacrificing a piece using
the fact that this skin is still in the
center
so c takes d5 of course uh black is
first to accept the challenge and now
bishop b5 with the check black has to
copy the queen
there are two options this knight or
this knight of course after knight after
d7 the queen is hanging
so this is why black is first to play
knight b to d7 and now white plays
long castle putting a lot of pressure on
d7 there are so many threats in this
position
bishop f6 followed by something to d7
also
something to d7 uh like brook takes e7
or bishop d7 just wins
in the spot so basically black has
a unique move in this position to
survive which is rook t8 and then
he tries to protect d7 withhold with all
his heart yeah
because now it's not that simple we take
on f6
g takes f6 if we take on d7 rook takes
c7
we check on b8 queen d8 check and then
we have to remember
that actually black is a piece up so
this is actually not working and
probably black is just winning in this
position
so how do we play in this position we
have to
remember that the only piece that is not
working
is the rook on h1 so this is a very
typical theme
we sacrifice an exchange on d7
the only move is rook takes e7 otherwise
the queen on e7 just falls
and rook h to d1
now this rook that was doing nothing
comes to d1
and again we have the same kind of
threats as before
and now black would love to have this
rook on a8 so he could play
rook d8 and then try to resist in this
position but then this rook
and this bishop on f8 are not
contributing to
the defense of the d7 square so this is
why
black is completely losing in this
position because now
we're threatening bishop f6 followed by
rook takes e7 just winning on this spot
so that's why benny tried queen e6
and now i wanna ask you what to play in
this position just pause the video there
is a very nice
combination checkmate in three moves
and i want to i want you to think about
forcing moves 4c moves are captures
checks and threats if we take on e6 yeah
after ftxc6 i mean we are not
going to check mate black so basically
uh
black is even better well black is not
better black is losing but after bishop
f6
i mean keen f7 black survives for some
more moves right
so there is a better move here in this
position so bishop takes d7 now this
force is black too
sorry guys to take with the knight on d7
i mean i've been recording for for 10
hours today some videos here so that's
why
i have this voice guy guys sorry
and uh again four c moves what should we
play in this position should we take on
e6 no
right because now after f takes e6 we
are actually losing in this position
so checks what are the checks in this
position queen takes c6
which is stupid and queen takes queen b8
sorry
at first glance this this looks stupid
because actually
it looks like we're just blundering the
queen but then we realized that
after another forcing move this actually
checkmate
on d8 so uh
white is a queen
and a piece down but actually manages to
check made on d8 so fantastic game
between elizabeth harmon and benny bats
and we have to say
that the real players were paul murphy
of course we all know paul morphy
and his aggressive play right we all
remember his
kins uh gun bit games and his opponent
was the
duke carl and the gang was played in
1858
in paris you as you guys know the
chess was played in a lot of cafes in in
paris they used to bet
uh a lot uh with this kind of games so
hope you guys enjoyed the
this uh this video and uh we'll cover
another game in the next one see you
have a nice day and take care yes stay
healthy
bye bye